in Prince Harry post a hidden message
about Megson to his Instagram in this
video Harry used the song this is the
one which later has lyrics including I'd
like to leave the country and burn the
town where I was born I'm told by
friends who still speak to Harry and
that privately this is really taking its
toll on him he is heartbroken
that's the rift between him and his
brother hasn't been something that they
can get over he is saddened by what has
happened within the royal family and sad
really to be having to make this choice
to step down from the royal family he
feels torn and I think behind that smile
and away from the cameras that there is
a lot of private anguish at a Rugby
event today Harry was stone-faced but
also sometimes laughing and making jokes
putting on a brave face but extremely
tight-lipped when asked about the drama
Harry ignored that question but
according to someone who was opposite
him apparently he laughed out loud at
that point so he hasn't entirely lost
his sense of humor only a limited amount
of press was invited to attend the event
well this could be our Prince Harry's
last engagement at Buckingham Palace as
a senior member of the royal family
while no announcement has been made
about their future roles Harry won't
reunite with Megan and Archie until
after he holds meetings in the UK next
week this has been quite a long period
of time that he's spent away from his
family I think certainly since Archer
was born the longest time that he and
Megan have been apart will be coming up
to ten days so I would imagine that once
these meetings are out the way and he's
going to be desperate to get on that
plane for Vancouver meanwhile Megan made
another surprise appearance in Canada
here she is visiting the organisation
justice for girls tea and sat down for
about an hour and a half the Duchess was
extremely kind and gracious and she put
all of us at ease
Tuesday's visit was Megan's second of
the day she also dropped by a woman
centre could she be sending a message
this is very much a signal I'm back at
work and this
is the source of what we're going to be
doing from now on as for William and
Kate's future could we see a baby number
for a Royal fantast and Kate replied I
don't think William wants anymore
[Music]